♪ ♪ ♪
- Martissant, vaste
quartier populaire au
sud-ouest de Port-au-Prince,
est normalement surpeuplé.
Mais depuis que
les affrontements entre gangs
ont éclaté ici en juin dernier,
le quartier se vide.
écécécoles, les commerces
et les marchés sont fermés.
Même les vendeuses de rue
ont disparu.
La station de bus est un des
rares lieux encore fréquentés.
Des dizaines de chauffeurs sont
toujours derrière leur volant,
malgré les dangers.
Martissant est incontournable
pour les chauffeurs. Le qu
est la seule porte d'entrée
et de sortie de Port-au-Prince
vers le sud du pays.
Un passage obligé stratégique
qugagagagangs ont pris en otage.
Adelin Decipo, alias Kawash,
est d'autant plus nerveux
sur la route qu'il a été
kidnappé à deux reprises.
La première fois, détenu
pendant troieseseseses, il était
convaincu qu'on allait le tuer.
Le lendemain de l'enlèvement,
les ravisseurs appellent
sa conjointe p
réclamer une rançon.
♪ ♪ ♪
- La population avait fui
la zone, qui était devenue
une zone de combat.
(tirs)
- Les violences et
les kidnappings sont tels
que Médecins sans fr
qui était dans le quartier
depuis 15 ans, a fermé
son hôpital. Il n'y a
pratiquement plus de services
nsnsnsnsnsnsnsns le secteur.
THIERRY GOFFEAU, chef, Médecins
sans frontières en Haïti
- La situation sécuritaire
était tellement mauvaise
qu'il n'était plus possible
pour nos staffs, mais
également pour les patients,
d'avoir accès à notre service.
Et donc, nous avons dû
changer de structure
pour nous relocaliser
dans un endroit plus stable et
plus accessible à la population.
RAPHAËL SMITH,
organisme La cour, la paix
- La vie est quasiment
anananananananans la capitale
haïtienne parce qu'il y a
un taux de violence
extrêmement élevé.
Beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup
de gens ont perdu leur vie,
beaucoup d'autres sont aussi
endommagés, beaucoup d'autres
sont aussi déplacés.
- Raphaël Smith travaille
un organisme qui aide des jeunes
à sortir des gangs de rue,
à trouver d'autres sources
de revenus que le crime.
Car le
est devenu une industrie.
En 2021, il y a eu près de
1000 enlèvements enregistrés;
c'est entre 15 et 20 kidnapping.
- Avec l'argent, on peut
tout faire : on peut acheter
des armes, on peut acheter
de nouvelles voitures,
de nouvelles maisons.
On peut aussi recruter
de nouveaux soldats,
on peut payer des soldats.
- Comme chef de gang,
plus on fait de kidnappings
rentables, plus on peut
s'imposer, faire grandir
sa milice et son influence
politique.
- Quand on dit "leader" dans
ces communautés, c'est quelqu'un
qui a la grande capacité de
mobiliser toute une foule.
Au moment des élections,
ces leaders-là auront
la possibilité de
rencontrer les candidats et,
ensemble, ils peuvent s'associer
et trouver des avantages après
les résultats des élections.
♪ (hip-hop) ♪
- Pour accroître leur pouvoir,
les chefs criminels ont aussi
recours aux réseaux sociaux
et, parfois, à la musique.
Le leader du groupe qui
a kidnappé Kawash fait du rap.
♪ (hip-hop) ♪
Leur complicité avec
les politiciens a anéanti
la crédibilité de toutes
les institutions publiques,
y compris celle des forces
de l'ordre. À Martissant,
le commissariat de police
a carrément été abandonné.
(en créole)
"La police, ça n'existe plus",
disent le chauffeur de bus et
sa femme. Même se faire escorter
par des policiers pour traverser
Martissant est risqué.
Kawash dit qu'il n'a pas
le choix de continuer; conduire
un bus est la seule façon
qu'il a de nourrir sa famille.
Lui et sa femme se résignent
à vivre la peur au ventre,
à chaque instant.
Le couple a récemment fui
la violence de Port-au-Prince
pour s'installer à Jacmel
avec ses trois enfants.
Mais Kawash doit toujours faire
le trajet vers la capitale;
il doit encore passer
par Martissant.